[Music]
[Music]
what happens in your brain when you read
code and what do we already know from
what happens in your brain when you read
text that we can use we don't have to
reinvent the wheel people know this and
we can just use what natural language
already knows
so what what do we know about code
reading or about reading language
when information enters your brain it
first enters the short term memory that
i guess you have heard of so firstly
information is stored in your short-term
memory for a brief period of time you
can think a bit of this
as your brain's ram
information can be stored there
briefly and it's a lot smaller than
long-term storage
and this has been known for a pretty
long time already so george miller in
the 1950s already said that your
short-term memory is really small it can
only hold between five and nine elements
so it's really really tiny
let's actually try that in practice so i
hope you are participating looking at
the chat as well in the meantime i hope
you are participating i will show you a
brief sentence just a sentence of three
words and it is your job at home to
remember and reproduce the sentence
but i will show it to you for a very
brief time it's like half a second it'll
be like
and it's gone
just to show you how bad how small your
short term memory is so i hope you're
watching at home there we go prepare
so i guess you're screaming at your
phone like this is unreasonably hard
harmons this is undoable we cannot do it
well i'm sorry that's just how small
your short term memory is
it can only hold between five and nine
elements actually newer research even
suggest it might be smaller it might be
between two and six elements in any case
it is really really small
so now you might wonder
well
if our short-term memory is so small
how do we do anything like how is it
possible that i can speak in a language
that isn't even my first language and
also wave my hands and also occasionally
look at the chat messages
how is that even possible with such a
tiny brain
well your short term memory doesn't work
alone it actually collaborates in your
brain with your working memory
so if you have read a sentence then from
the short term memory it is sent on
processed through the working memory
but in the working memory not just
information from your short term memory
is stored but also information from your
long-term memory your long-term memory
really helps your working memory process
and of that we will also see a small
example so i'll show you yet another
sentence and there you can see that your
short-term memory can be supported by
your long-term memory here we go i hope
you're ready for yet another sentence
so that felt doable i guess right
it was still hard i know it was still
quite hard but at least now you could
make sense of what was there probably
you could understand a few letters
not because it was substantially like
inherently easier but those letters are
things you've practiced
so often you've looked at letters that
you can very quickly recognize and
remember them
and i will show you even how
your long-term memory can support your
short-term memory so that you can
remember a sentence
something that seemed
undoable just a few minutes ago
suddenly turns out to be relatively easy
if your long-term memory helps you so
i'll show you a third sentence and i am
sure
everyone can do it if you just like
don't blink and don't miss the sentence
you can remember this like 100 here we
go
so that was easy right
even though it was the exact same length
of the first sentence and the second
sentence
but what happens here is you can quickly
understand this
remember this why because you're not
remembering half a circle and a circle
with a coma attached to it and a
catholic cross and a long stripe and a
tiny circle you're not remembering like
that
you can
immediately recognize the letters
because you've seen them so often and
then not only are you recognizing the
letters you are recognizing words you
are saying
not in your memory c a t
l o v e no it's like cat it's one thing
so those things are retrieved from your
long-term memory you know the letters
you know what a cake is and what laws is
so the number of things you have to
remember now has suddenly decreased from
all the individual letters which are way
too many
to three things which easily fit your
short term memory so here you see in
action the collaboration between long
and short term memory
so now let's let's circle back to
programming because it sort of turned
into an introductory cognitive science
lecture which is also interesting i
guess but i know most of you came here
to listen to know about getting better
at reading code what happens in your
brain when you read code
so let's look at three different
programs because with the different
forms of memory short-term memory
long-term memory and working memory
come different processes related to code
different reasons why code can be
confusing
so let's look at this program it's a
program in a programming language called
apl which is sort of a weird and
esoteric programming language that most
most professional programmers don't know
it's very old it's from like 1960 and
it's mainly
meant to do vector calculations
so i'm just going to assume that this
program to you is confusing
because the program is 2 2 2 2 2 t n
like this is the program this is an
entire program in apo
so why are you confused by this
it's it's because of the t
you don't know what t does
you probably know what
do you know that it's twos and i will
tell you that the n is the input
parameter to this program
so you know what that is it will be a
number as well but then
what is that t
thing
so this is an issue with your long-term
memory right you just don't know what
the t is
it's not because you're not capable of
processing this program you just don't
know what the thing is no one ever told
you what it is so you have a long-term
memory issue
this program a java program
also might be confusing to you
especially if you're not a trained java
programmer if you're
like me mainly using python as a
programming language then this might be
confusing because it overloads your
short term memory
if you really want to understand it you
have to remember many things public
clause binary calculator public static
void main end and system output line
integer binary string
if you're an
experienced java programmer you probably
know that public laws and public static
void main it's all not so important
probably where the importance are is in
the binary string and binary calculation
but you can only see that if you're not
all too confused by all the fluff that
is there so this program is a bit fluffy
and if you're not used to it this will
be heavy on your short term memory
here is a third program by the way they
all do the same all these programs
calculate the binary representation of
the number n
here's a program that's also confusing
probably but it's confusing for yet
another reason
here the program is confusing because
you have to do so many things it is your
working memory in this program that is
being
stressed it's being being stretched to
its limits
because what is going on here you can't
really see probably if you would
actually have to debug this program you
would take a pen you'd say okay well
let's just try this for the value n okay
so n is seven what happens okay so b is
the empty string and then this loop goes
from
seven to zero okay so then n
is okay that's seven divided by two so
that's three because it's rounded
okay so then b string is okay so it's a
string zero okay what happens in the
next iteration
so you just have to work really hard to
understand this
if you're somewhat familiar with with
programming languages even if you're not
familiar with basic you will know what
most of this does you know let's you
know the equal sign assignments you know
the empty string you know a for loop
your your long-term memory is fine right
the issue here is your working memory
you have to do so many things
so you might be like yes but what you've
just showed us just means that reading
code is really hard
look you showed us all these types of
confusing confusion
and that might lead to what i something
sometimes think is so sad that people
they look at a certain library like i
sometimes do this oh i need a partial
library in python let me go on github
and then you look at code that someone
else has written and you look at it
you're like
yeah this is so hard to read it's
probably easier if i just write my own
parser framework
which i think very often is not really
true
but we think it's true because we have
practiced writing so much that's where
our fluency is but we've never really
practiced reading we don't really have
theories for reading so of course it is
hard if i ask non-trained people to do a
marathon tomorrow they'd be like that is
super hard because i never did a
marathon
but a marathon isn't inherently hard
right i know if you've never ran a
marathon that probably sounds like
terrible to you but it isn't inherently
hard i mean you can already walk it's
just you do that many many times
it's only hard if you've never practiced
if you if you practice a lot doing a
marathon is not so bad actually and it's
sort of the same with code where we're
dreaming code where it sounds terrible
but that's because you never practice
but you could practice you can actually
get a lot better at code reading if you
would just practice
so here's a few things that you can do
what i hope that you do after watching
this video the next time that you
actually encounter code that is hard to
read i hope that you will reflect and
you will think okay so that was
uncomfortable
is this a long-term memory issue is it
just really hard because i don't know
syntax
is this a short-term memory
issue is this just really hard because i
have to remember many things and i don't
yet know what is and what isn't
important
or is this a working memory issue where
like okay i think i can oversee
all the syntax elements and all the
elements that play a role but i don't
know how they interact with each other
these three different
problems have different solutions so if
your problem is i don't know this syntax
then
you can learn
you could practice syntax i know it's
not really a thing we do
but it works just really really well
so you can make a stack of cards called
flash cards where on one hand side you
put the the prompt so you for example in
the apl example you could put on one
side the t which actually isn't d it's
called encode and then on the other side
of the card you say encode and this is
how you could learn all the apl keywords
that are all operators but of course
this doesn't have to be apl it can also
be python where you say for loop on one
hand side and then the syntax of the for
loop on the other side or if there's a
certain um a certain api that you want
to learn
retrieve a file and then what what you
have to do is on the other side of the
card if you practice that you'll get a
bigger vocabulary of syntax so then
you're less likely to have these
long-term memory issues
if you have working memory issues on the
other hand if it's very very hard to
process the individual elements of code
and how they interact with each other
you can support your working memory
your working memory is basically it's
your short-term memory applied to a
certain problem so it also has this very
small size limitation but you could help
it for example something you could do is
you could have a tracing table like you
see here where you step by step
analyze what's going on so you say okay
in the initialization and the seven and
two is seven very systematically uh b
string is the empty string and n one is
also seven and then step by step okay
loop iteration one this is what happens
iteration two this is what happens and
you can do this manually as you'd see me
do here but clearly of course this can
also be done supported by an ide where
you really systematically step through
the code to try to gain an understanding
and make it easier for your working
memory to understand because you offload
the important information somewhere and
this could be on a literal piece of
paper or you can put all of this as
watches on variables in your ide but at
least you're offloading some of your
working memory elsewhere so that you can
process code more easily
so that is the good news you can get
better at reading code firstly by
self-reflecting and understanding
what type of confusion are we dealing
with
what you can also do as a really really
nice technique to remember
code is sorry to diagnose code reading
skills is to remember code so if i show
this code to you for a little bit just
well maybe not half a second as i did
with the sentences but
three minutes for example and then i
take the code away
and now i would ask you
reproduce that code as best as you can
if you do that you'll get a really nice
insight into what you know
because some of these parts like the
highlighted parts here come from your
long-term memory probably public class
blood static void main you didn't really
remember that you just remembered define
a class and define a main method and
then later on you use your long-term
memory to reproduce the exact syntax
because you already know it whereas some
things in this program
highlighted here in green come from your
short term memory remembering that this
was in search and sort remembering that
this variable was called array and the
values in it were 45 and 12 etc that is
all coming from your short term memory
and then it comes together
and actually at this time little
marketing for my research we are
exploring this so if you're just
interested in helping science figure it
out you can go to felina.com test where
we have a little memory exercise in java
for you
you